do you have a gap right at the core of
economic policy i'm talking about the
shadow chancellor here we're hearing
he's lost his mojo he predicted a
triple-dip recession it didn't happen is
Ed Balls really not kind of punching
above his weight hey listen I think
there's no doubt not least on the basis
of what Ed Miliband said this morning on
the Andrew Marr program that aid is
going to be an absolutely key central
and I think they paused to figure in
terms of taking that case to the
conservatives about why the flat lined
the economy for three years but also
setting out the kind of structural
changes we need to the economy so that
we can grow an errand are we to higher
living standards in the future hmm but
he's lost his mojo is what I said he and
he predicted that triple dip recession
there wasn't even a double so there's a
double-dip he was no forgive me stories
come and go in the newspapers I think
what's important is having a plan for
the kind of economy that we want having
the intellectual rigor and policy
strength to actually be able to devise
the solutions for the challenges the
country faces and in that sense I think
we've got a team that can take us to
minister I make sure you two don't
always see eye to eye isn't it yeah you
had a stand-up rowdy for the very least
about Europe listen I've worked with it
for 20 years in fact I've worked with
both heads for 20 years in that sense
one of the resolutions we need when we
moved into a position in 2010 because we
had front row seats at the TB jeebies
was we were never going to allow any
differences any personality issues to
get in the way of our shared response up
behind closed doors you must speak as
you see I mean you know any you know
each other so well you've grown up
politically but I think it's I think
it's a good thing that as a team you can
debate discuss and then decide and move
forward that's what we've done that's
why I think actually we haven't done
what previous generations of liberal
politicians have done when they went
into a position which is to form a
circular filing scored and about a
decade get their act together the fact
that we are ahead in the opinion polls
the fact we are making plans for the
kind of country that we think labour
could deliver after 2015 i think is
testimony to the extent to which we've
shown we will work together in the
national interest